[Music]
I'm so glad that I feel so much more
comfortable I'm so glad that we did well
tonight I was nervous I really was but
the fact that we could do this dance and
have it be something he was amazing for
choreographing something like that my
gains 70ish comes over like two years it
was really really hurtful the way people
reacted I was diagnosed with PCOS
polycystic ovary syndrome a hormone
imbalance what is the remedy what are
you doing at in order to sort of combat
this condition so basically I mean every
woman is different right so either it's
with birth control or it's with another
medication but the fact that you can
test your levels and know what it is and
work with your doctor to fix it is
amazing and that's really just what I
want is for people to have awareness
because so many women have it and they
don't know and if you don't catch it in
time it leads to too many things but
including ovarian cancer and breast
cancer and all kinds of things that
women deal with all the time and they
could have been avoided have you seen
some transformation in the weeks that
you guys have been working total I mean
it's just a little different Sasha from
week one when we've met you know and you
can see from the first meeting and now
and you're saying you lost 15 pounds
we're doing lots of exercise every
rehearsal started with 3045 minutes
like literally workout I can make her
run we're doing push-ups with us we're
doing jump ropes we do lots of different
exercises to build up the stamina to
build up the strength and we're gonna
continue doing it and I want to see the
whole journey of the transformation you
know it's not the end yet you know
you're gonna lose another 50 pounds and
hopefully because then they come to go I
mean that's what you think that's what
you want yeah yeah it is I just want to
be healthy
[Music]